boris johnson has never been under such
pressure from his own party the
opposition and the people of britain who
elected him the question did he attend a
summer party in the garden of number 10
downing street in may 2020 the whole
country was in lockdown around 40 people
appear to have been in breach of coveted
restrictions first he tried to address
the british people
i want to apologize
i know the rage
they feel
with me
and with the government i lead
when they think that in downing street
itself
the rules are not being properly
followed by the people who make the
rules
and when i went into that garden just
after six on the 20th of may
2020
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work event
but mr speaker
with hindsight
i should have sent
everyone back inside
after months of deceit and deception
the pathetic spectacle of a man who's
run out of road
his defense his defense that he didn't
realize he was at a party
it is so ridiculous
that it's actually offensive to the
british public
he's finally been forced to admit what
everyone knew that when the whole
country was locked down he was hosting
boozy parties in downing street
is he now going to do the decent thing
and resign
johnson didn't say yes or no
i want to repeat that
i thought it was a work event and
apologizing again and telling opposition
leader kirsten he should wait for the
results of an inquiry into revelations
of several parties in downing street and
whitehall i regret very much that we did
not do things differently uh that
evening the labour leader persisted
talking of the deep offense caused to
relatives of people dying from covid at
the time and of the millions who were
obeying the rules
starmer repeatedly rounded on johnson
the party's over prime minister
the only question is will the british
public kick him out will his party kick
him out or will he do the decent thing
and resign
this crisis is being called partygate by
the media johnson is trying to ride it
out much rest though with the outcome of
the inquiry into downing street and
whitehall parties and what the police do
about the latest revelation
more rest though on whether the
conservative party decides johnson is
now a liability and has to go
andrew simmons al jazeera